la 11e circonscription un espace mi
rural mi-urbain rassemblant 110000
yvelinois qui avait été lu en 2017 nadia
et de la république en marche nommé
ministre délégué auprès de la cohésion
des territoires la députée avait dû
quitter son poste en 2020 pierre lui ce
candidat pour assurer le maintien de la
circonscription au parti du président
emmanuel macron est éliminée dès le
premier tour et on retrouve un duel
gauche droite entre le républicain
philippe benassaya et sandrine grand
gang de génération s pour le second tour
de la législative partielle de septembre
2020 nous allons aborder deux
thématiques au cours de la prochaine
demi heure philippe benassaya vous avez
choisi de parler de sécurité sandrine
grand-combe vous souhaitez évoqué
l'environnement qu'on est face à une
crise sans précédent sur le plan
sanitaire sur le plan environnemental
sur une climatique et donc sur le plan
social parce que bien sûr tout est lié
et et il faut qu'on soit en capacité
finalement de proposer dès maintenant
des mesures qui qu'ils soient à la
hauteur des défis que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui quand on parle de sécurité
c'est la première de nos libertés il n'y
a pas de sécurité sans liberté ya pas de
liberté sont sécurité je veux dire par
là c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce pays n'est
plus tenu sentiment d'insécurité comboul
abidi sentiment d'impunité laxisme
pénale philippe benassaya l'emportent
finalement avec 57% des suffrages le 27
septembre deux ans plus tard le député
souhaite être réélu et à d'ores et déjà
annoncé sa candidature
c'est un travail très intéressant que
j'ai envie de poursuivre d'abord pour
défendre les habitants dans une
circonscription mais également défendre
nos élus qui ont besoin de relais au
niveau national pour pouvoir engranger
les projets et puis bien sûr être aux
côtés de nos artisans aux commerçants et
de nos entreprises
génération s n'a pas encore nommé son
candidat pour le premier tour prévu le
12 juin prochain le parti attend de voir
les autres candidatures de gauche pour
adopter une stratégie quant à la
république en marche l'objectif sera la
reconquête il y aura des députés de la
république en marche en tout cas des
candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions yvelinoise après benoît
hamon pour le parti socialiste en 2012
nadia et de l erp em en 2017 et philippe
benassaya en 2020 trois voix semble
ouverte à cinq mois du premier tour
autre candidat potentiel la france
insoumise et le rassemblement national
qui étaient tous deux aux alentours de
7% lors du précédent scrutin